look a lot of people asked me off and
they say Pat I know you're from Iran I
know you were born there you lived there
from 78 to 89 how do you feel about the
way media paints Iran to be you know
there there must be bad people it must
be just bombing all the time going on
how do you feel about the way they penne
run out to me but the reality is for me
when someone asked me that question I
said listen I lived in Iran for 10 years
and I remember every time I watch the
two channels that we had u.s. is the
evil empire death upon America America
is evil all they care about is
capitalism and money and greed and all
this other stuff right but but at the
same time for me you know I was born
there so for me it's almost like you
know our parents get a divorce
and you're in the middle one says it's
all your dad's fault
the other says all your mom's fault
whose fault is it really so today I'm
going to take a complete different angle
on how I view what's going on between
u.s. and Iran and we're gonna go way
back and some of the stuff I talk about
you can agree with some of the stuff
you're not gonna agree with some of the
some even upset you but the reality is
if anything about this video makes you
want to go research about what is going
on with US UK and Iran this video did
its purpose so here's what we're gonna
cover in today's episode number one is
current iran state of economy how bad is
it over there is it as bad as people
make it out to be number two relevant
countries that have to do with
everything that's going on with Iran
continuously then timeline because a lot
of times when we look at what's going on
today how do we get to where we are
today so we'll kind of roll back all the
way back to 1908 and then what
presidents in u.s. did well with leaders
or prime ministers up Iran and then my
final thoughts on what I think's taking
place and how some things will change
and some things may not change and the
one thing you don't hear a lot of people
talk about it keeps cap it into Iran and
there's a reason for we'll talk about
that at the end of the episode so let's
get right into it current state of
economy in Iran number one unemployment
rate currently for young Iranians is 27
percent and those graduating from
universities 40 percent so that's not a
good thing right there when you're
looking at that because people cannot
find jobs especially the youth number
two inflation is estimated to be at 40
percent although professor
Steve Hankey from John Hopkins
University who was a senior economist to
President Reagan says there's no way in
the world it's at forty percent it's at
least at 250 percent but again 40 to 250
percent is still terrible for any
country on top of that families who want
to go feed their kids today in the last
12 months meat prices are up 57 percent
milk and egg up 37 percent vegetables up
47 percent that's basic shopping outside
of that their currency the rial has lost
60 percent of its value against the US
dollar in the last 12 months
today a dollar equals 42 thousand riyals
some are even saying they're spending
over a hundred thousand reals per dollar
and last but not least in this category
would oil
they've lost 10 billion dollars of
revenues and oil in last 12 months I'll
give you some data for you to be
thinking about it from May of 2018 to
October of 2018 comparing that five
month run to November of 2018 to March
of 2019 here's how many barrels they
sold in the first five months versus the
second five months ready first five
months to China they were selling
590,000 barrels a day to China the
second five months only 360,000 to India
563 thousand barrels per day twenty
three hundred thousand Japan was buying
a hundred and forty-nine thousand
barrels per day to fifty thousand Taiwan
was doing thirty two thousand barrels a
day to zero turkey was doing 120
thousand barrels a day to 73,000 Greece
was doing 85 thousand barrels a day to
zero and Italy was doing a hundred
twenty-one thousand barrels a day to
zero this is real stuff here I mean
imagine you're selling a product and
you're selling so much of it all of a
sudden everything flips nearly 50
percent 80 percent
no one's ordering oils from you anymore
why is that so if Iran was a business
they're about to go out of business if
they go out to space I mean you cannot
go all of a sudden what all these
customers are buying your products and
suddenly 50% 70% it's down this is not a
good thing for a business let alone a
nation that needs to figure out a way to
feed families and support and create
jobs right but every time you see a
story like this
you got a look behind closed doors to
see who's pulling strings is there
anybody that's influencing this and
here's some of the countries I want you
to be thinking about us obviously UK
Israel Saudi Arabia and any God Russia
Venezuela and Lebanon obviously Lebanon
because Lebanon and Iran share a common
enemy which is Israel an enemy of an
enemy is a friend so Israel is an enemy
to Iran and Israel is an enemy to
Lebanon which means they're allies and I
think in 2008 the president of Lebanon
went to Tehran and struck a deal
economically in military and you know
they both kind of have things that they
like right so you got to kind of look at
some of these countries but let's go
back in time line and see how this whole
thing came about obviously there are
certain things that are causing this but
let's go back to 1908 1908 anglo-persian
oil company gets started right people
find that iran's got some oil oh my gosh
what if and you know every time this
happens money opportunity greed we gotta
get a hold of this what if we can get
some money here and at that time Iran
doesn't have all the technology to be
able to get the oil and UK did Britain
did so they came in will help you but
they struck a deal with them in 1914
they came in and they say we'll help you
but we want to own 50% of all of it
imagine you are Iran it's your country
it's your oil but Britain strikes a deal
with you to own 51% of it and this is
the whole anglo-persian oil company
we're talking about which later on in
1954 they changed the name to BP British
Petroleum you've heard about him right
so that's 1914 now let's talk about some
of the leaders 1925 to 1941 Reza Khan
Reza Shah Pahlavi who is Mohammad Reza
pal of his father becomes the Shah of
Iran from 1925 to 1941 then in 1941 he
appoints his son his son becomes the
Shah and he stays from 1941 to 1979 this
is very important to know why this is
taking place from the father to the son
the father had a very strong military
was a great general he was a warrior
tough guy would push people around
everybody respected him from his
military you know or record that he had
and his son was a little bit
his son spoke six or seven languages he
was more of the better well-spoken
politician a little bit gentler a
different kind of approach he had but it
was in his father's shadows he comes and
takes over right then in 1951 Mossad
death who in Iran comes out and becomes
the prime minister of Iran he comes out
and says we got to nationalize the soil
situation why are we giving it to
Britain why are we giving him so much
money
Britain gets upset and similar to
sanctions Britain imposes the embargo
and halt exports which is now really
good because again Iran cannot make
money because people are not buying
products and most others to kind of make
a comparison of whom were saw that was
Mosaddegh was a socially similar to like
a Bernie Sanders with the communistic
party in Iran today really liked him and
they supported him so some say he was a
communist he says I'm not a communist
but some said he is a communist so it
was kind of that going on and Britain's
obviously not happy about it so in 1953
CIA and mi6 which is the British
intelligence they team up together to
create a coup and what happens they kick
most others out and most other ends up
going to living in a small town away
from everybody in a place doesn't bother
no one they just kind of wanted to get
rid of him and he goes out there and
he's gone right so then the Reza Reza
pal if he comes back monitors up Hal avi
they liked him because he was good with
the Western nations goes back and starts
creating commerce money all that stuff
goes back to where was that before by
the way CIA document released six years
later validates that the coup did take
place influenced by CIA and the mi6
these documents are not public you can
actually go look at him so 1963 the Shah
he comes out and says look he gets
inspired he sees what's going on in
America with capitalism with education
he says I want to do a similar thing he
admired what the West was doing and a
lot of Iranians didn't like his level of
admiration for us right so he comes out
with launches this program called the
white revolution and here's what some of
the things happen from 1963 to 1978
because of him launching this white
revolution
number one Iran students the illiterate
in rate was very very high in Iran
people couldn't read people couldn't
ride and it was something everybody
talked about he took it from 1.5 million
students in 1963 in all of Iran to over
10 million students by the time 1978
came around total schools multiplied 3.2
four times schools all over the place
because he understood the value of
education in order increase the economy
of a nation education wise they were
spending 45 billion riyals from 63 to
sixty-seven raised it 273 billion reals
from 68 to 72 and eventually 551 billion
riyals from 73 to 77 the one thing that
he did that he didn't like that was
taking place in Iran he wanted to give a
lot of women's rights back to them so
woman's right to vote
you know woman's right to run for office
be a lawyer be a judge be before that
they couldn't do it and on top of that
this one's gonna sound strange to a lot
of people I advise you to go actually
research this he increased woman's age
legal age of getting married to 15
because it used to be 38 and by the way
I think today it's back down to 13 and
even some making go petition to even
marry younger than 13 he raised it to 15
so you're looking at some of the stuff
and people are saying that really took
place yes go do your own research you'll
see it for yourself
obviously Iran's personal income the
citizens went up tremendously and oil
revenue went from 555 million in a year
to 20 billion in 1976 so you can see
Iran's becoming stronger and stronger
and stronger with this white revolution
that he announced right so even though
at this point shots getting a lot of
attention because economies do good
people are making money there is still a
community of people that don't like what
he's doing extreme conservatives were
why are women getting so much power you
know why are they taking down their
scarf you know they're loose a tea why
are they taking it down I don't want
that this is not what he runs about
we're becoming too American our kids are
losing control they're too free I don't
want to see any discuss so the spiritual
leaders were not too happy about the
Shah right and the Shah had a his own
method of secret service called the
SAVAK
and the SAVAK sometimes was pushing
around the today party and he had three
thousand political prisoners that he was
hanging onto and at this point the Shah
is doing interviews on TV and he's
coming across a little bit too confident
okay and he's saying stuff about
blue-eyed people and the brah brown-eyed
people are teaching the blue-eyed people
stuff and you know all this stuff is
taking place because the blue-eyed
people are taking too many sleeping
pills and you know they're not really as
focused as we are and one day we're
gonna be one of the most powerful
nations in the world top five passing
possibly UK he's saying this in
interviews and you can tell when you're
looking at him he's a little bit proud
about what's going on and maybe to the
point where it's rubbing certain people
the wrong way right is what he's doing
so whenever you do that sometimes
there's gonna be some people that are
secretly creating a certain rising right
they're getting a little bit upset with
you and they're not happy about about
the kind of power you have
so in nineteen seventy eight here's what
happens while this is going on Jimmy
Carter December 31st of 1977 he comes
and they do a toast okay hey Iran's an
incredible Empire and Jimmy Carter says
some nice words about the Shah with the
toast Jimmy Carter leaves the moment he
leaves slowly things start happening in
Iran and it gets started with a
Ayatollah Khomeini who was an exile for
14 years from Iran and he first went to
Iraq and now he's living in France in
Paris and he starts making tapes and
they record these tapes and they bring
it underground to Iran and they
distribute it to ten people than a
hundred people then a thousand people
then take hey go
keep keep copying it keep copying and
give it to people keep copying and
giving it to people and it goes 200,000
then all of sudden millions then
suddenly an event takes place I believe
August 20th 1978 in a city called
Abaddon Abaddon was where the refineries
were at it's like in Peninsula type of a
place really nice place and they had a
movie theater called cinema Rex the
reason why I know it's around August
20th
around that time is because I'm Toby 28
1978 so I'm posting MRX file that's when
I'm born so this theater has 400 people
there
wives mothers kids fathers they're
watching movies in around like movies
was a big deal and everybody is at the
movies it was always sell selling out
there at the movies so somebody comes
and closes the door locks it puts the
place on fire 400 innocent people died
that night across the street is a police
station by the way so Khomeini and his
people blamed Saavik for doing it which
is Shahs secret service the shots people
like we didn't do this and they're
blaming it on home a nice people to
create a blame now no one till today can
100% say whether it's a bach or whether
it's how many people but all we know is
this took place and the group that was
able to get the most mileage out of this
wasn't sure it was home any and all of a
sudden there was an uprising
he's killing innocent people he's now
worth a billion dollars he's so powerful
and chars like what do I do about this
he calls us oh don't worry about it
kissing hey don't worry about it it's
okay nothing's a big deal
I need help it's nothing and in all of
thunder was too late way too late by
that time
Jimmy Carter calls him and says I think
you need to leave your country and what
ashhadu January 16th Shauna's family
leave Iran and they leave completely
leaving Ron and a couple weeks after
that on February 1st how many shows back
up to Iran first time in 14 years and
when he shows up he lands at the airport
they had to move because people couldn't
even let this guy get out and bothering
my family I had a group of people in my
family that were so glad the shot was
done because no man she'll be worth two
billion dollars and the Shah was rich at
that time no man should be worth two
billion dollars he lives on 10 different
castles why should somebody be as rich
as this man and look at the celebration
he put for the 2500 years of pala V and
spent all this money for Iran and
prestige and fame it was like a party
and it was the country's money why
should he do something like that it was
an uproar people we're not happy about
it
anyways Khomeini shows up well Khomeini
shows up immediately he gets rid of a
lot of the internal military a lot of
people get killed a lot of people get
killed they were trying to run away a
lot of shots general get killed you can
see a list them that get killed anyway
it's fast forward November 79 you got 52
hostages that get taken under Khomeini
from
u.s. US hostages are kept 1979 November
then in 1980 Shah dies in Egypt of
cancer 1980 to 1988 war starts between
Iran and Iraq I live when this war
happened in Tehran Iran that's why they
never I never forget us getting bombed
167 times in a day I'll never forget the
whistling sound our glass windows all of
them were taped up with X's okay imagine
four at two x's like this they were all
taped up because when blasts would drop
the glass broke many times when a glass
would drop you didn't want the glass to
shatter everywhere you want it to drop
right there so your kids you don't get
all this cuts and all this stuff
every window imagine all your windows
have tapes like that that's what our
windows look like my dad would come with
black tape and it would tape everything
up right no one's trying to be pretty at
this point there's war going on and you
would hear all these tammyjo tera Joe
Allah attack Hermes you know the fact
that a plane has crossed our borders so
that goes for eight years 1.5 million
lives by the way you know who supported
Iraq us did u.s. supported Iraq going
against Iran why US was funding and
helping out Saddam Hussein
they weren't hoping Khomeini on at this
time and in 1981 January 20th Reagan
gets a like that the day he gets elected
they released the 52 hostages and it
comes to us Khomeini said hey you know
what I think this guy's gonna go to war
with us let's just release so he wasn't
afraid the way he behaved Khomeini was
not afraid of Carter but he was afraid
of Reagan he said I think Reagan's gonna
do something to us I don't think
Carter's gonna do anything cuz he's too
nice of a guy nobody was afraid of
Carter in Iran but they were afraid of
Reagan that's the movement when you're
looking at 88 Iran's Airbus plane gets
shot down by US ship and they said it
was an accident but it costs 290
people's lives
innocent 66 were children that I mean if
it happens to your country you're gonna
say it's an accident you're not gonna
believe it so Iran the u.s. is saying it
was an accident we're sorry Iran saying
what do you mean you're sorry 290 people
you're sorry sixty-six kids what sorry
these are not military this is not a war
you didn't bomb a place you shot down
one of our planes so that's the
confidence till today no one really
knows 100%
it was an accident or intentional then
in 1995 Clinton puts all these sanctions
on them 1995 2003 Iran suspense their
uranium enrichment project that they had
okay no problem we're willing to agree
to this because they wanted to go back
and forth negotiate they want export oil
again hey we gotta sell this stuff
because our country's got to stay put
and in 2006 to 2010 US succeeds with
four rounds of sanctions against Iran
stop enriching uranium stop exporting
weapons
you know banking restrictions and trade
and travel restrictions this is to Iran
for them so things are tough so Iran's
used to all this stuff over the last two
decades because the constantly happens
to them 2012 Iran's currency loses 80
percent to the dollar record lows they
ever experienced I was just seven years
ago by the way and then outside of that
Obama strikes the deal with John Kerry
and Joe Biden where they give around 150
billion dollars some states fifty
billion dollars and some say was only
one point eight billion dollars in cash
but regardless they strike a deal with
hopes of them no longer creating the
uranium nuclear bombs and in 2018 Trump
comes and he says nope I am NOT gonna do
that deal he withdraws from the deal
with Iran and then a couple months later
after that boom new sanctions and Iran
sitting there saying wait a minute
what's going on over here and then
Iran's experiencing this okay so this is
a bit of back story of what's going on
now let's talk presidency does it match
what happens with certain presidents so
when Mohammad Municipality was president
from 41 to 79 this was during FDR Truman
Eisenhower Kennedy LBJ Nixon Ford and
car to keep this in mind he got along
with Eisenhower he got along with Nixon
he got along with Ford he didn't get
along with Carter and JFK wasn't a fan
of him and LBJ wasn't a fan of him so he
was kind of like going back and forth
trying to figure out so Eisenhower liked
them Nixon liked him you know certain
Republican presidents like them but
Democratic presidents didn't like him so
you know it was a battle when one
president would come he could strike a
deal when the other person would come he
couldn't do any kind of a deal so it's
important to know that and then after
that you know how meny shows up 79 to 89
with harmony being the president of Iran
and and after that then you have
rafsanjani from 89 to 97 and hot MA hot
to me from 97 to oh five then I'm an ad
job is from 2005 to 2013 and an Iran's
current president is Hassan rouhani
who's been president since 2013 to
present by the way the Supreme Leader
went from being home a knee to them
being Khamenei here's the one thing you
gotta know about harmony while Shah was
ruling Iran from 41 to 79 a lot of
people complain about the fact that the
Shah was worth 1 billion dollars
according to Reuters Reuters Khamenei
the current supreme leader for nearly 30
years I want to say since 89 Khamenei
according to Reuters is worth a minimum
of 95 billion dollars and no one knows
how his word 95 billion dollars a lot of
people are saying he took the money from
the Iranian people from the government
and no one could figure that because
Khomeini was all about God and harmony
was a little bit about business Khamenei
was more business for many was more
about hey I love Iran I want to be able
to do something harmony was a little bit
more the business guy but those are some
of the numbers you need to keep in mind
about what's going on with Iran well
it's got a lot of money Khamenei's
family and himself got very what again
you can go verify this stuff and look it
up for yourself so you got to keep this
amount a lot of people ask is this ever
gonna stop at in my answers I don't
think it's gonna ever stop why here's
why the more conflicts in the Middle
East the more control who us-uk the big
empires the more conflict in the Middle
East the more control the less conflict
the more powerful they're becoming Iran
from 63 to 78 they were grown steadily
they became a superpower in the Middle
East everything was at peace they're
creating their own oil they're creating
their own commerce they're creating
their own military hey why is it why is
Iran getting a little too powerful we
can't let that happen
hey cool give another cool here's a
formula for cool
do another one do another one do another
one and typically coos are caused by the
following formula not all the time but
many times this is how it takes place
when a Republican president is a
president in the US and somebody who's
running Iran is pro-israel
pro-business pro-america it's peace no
issues okay Eisenhower Shah Nixon Shah
for cha no it's just we're good to go
when a Democratic president is president
of United States and in Iran there
someone have a little bit of conflict
with Israel they're not fully
pro-business they're not fully pro u.s.
there's no conflict but when a
Democratic president is in the US as a
Democrat and Iran is being led by
somebody who's pro-israel pro-us
pro-western Pro capitalism then there
could be possible war and when there's a
Republican president and it's the
complete opposite it's also possible war
now this word it's not a war let's go
you know jets flying bomb no war could
be a you know right now Iran's calling
this an economic terrorism okay hey
they're hurting us economically is what
they're saying
this is economic terrorism doesn't
necessarily have to cut sanctions I can
make money if I can make money and China
India all these countries are no longer
buying for me what am I going to do now
and this is why I put Venezuela because
Iran and Venezuela are facing similar
problems sanction sanctions this is why
Iran in Venice what they get along
because they understand each other and
they say we understand your pain u.s. is
kind of bullying you you're also an oil
country used to be on the riches look at
the sanctions and Iran so yeah us too
yes sir there's there's a little bit
that going on there that they get along
with that Saudi Arabia doesn't want to
see Iran be up there why because they
want to compete in the oil and they want
to have a monopoly they want to compete
in our marketplace right and obviously
last but not least Israel is not a fan
of Iran because you know the whole thing
again an enemy of an enemy is a friend
so all of those things taking place so
last but not least this boolean thing
that's taking place with superpowers
very simple formula to bully a country
like Iran very simple formula number one
is create sanctions with strong requests
strong sanctions very strong sanctions
you tie him up now I was in what was
that I was at the can France I was a
staying at their Monaco and I want to
can and I'm in the beach and I'm talking
to I can't say the name but I can just
tell you a very high-profile political
leader in the Middle East that is
running 21 countries
financially I
that's all I can tell you who this
person is and we're having our and have
conversation together and he tells me
says look I have a lot of allies in Iran
I got a lot of friends in Iran he says
but I'm from one of the countries in the
Middle East
he says Pat I can't do nothing with them
we had to cut every business ties
everything lending everything because of
what US said because if one the bad side
of us then a lot of the relationships we
have have to go through us because
everybody wants to be good with the US
so the moment they had the sanctions
Iran felt it immediately immediately
number two formulate a bully is befriend
and support their number-one enemy so
what happens
Carter leaves how many's in Iran us
support to u.s. supports Iraq Saddam
Hussein why because remember the
president the rule of Romania at that
time was anti us anti Israel and the
president of us at that time was Reagan
Pro us hey this is happening no problem
we're gonna be friend you're who
we're gonna be friend your enemy which
is Saddam Hussein and one and a half
million people get killed so so that's
the part about befriending the enemy
number three infiltrate the nation with
opposition internally send people
internally to create opposition
internally and last but not least it's a
very simple formula that's used for long
to a very very long time
create an internal division when you
create an internal division it's very
simple they did it with the Shah pinned
our people against the Shah for what
everybody's creating jobs people are
making money why if you ever go study
different revolutions the one thing that
you'll notice about the Iranian
Revolution against all the other
revolutions French Revolution all the
other revolutions there's four things
all the revolutions have in common none
of those four were happening in Iran
none of them what a shot why did it take
place the word spreading this campaign
message has so much influence and again
it started with Carter UK u.s. CIA mi6
US UK again let's divide Iran and this
is the formula that what history tells
us so lucky and close and I want to
share my final thoughts hopefully to the
people in Iran that are watching is we
have a lot of value to news in Iran that
watches content and even other folks
around the world that are you know
watching this unit this thing here this
is what I would tell you today I had a
former FBI agent who retire two years
ago
years FBI agent undercover he worked
with Russian mafia three La Cosa Nostra
families he worked with Sinaloa cartel
he worked undercover on a lot of
different projects right very decorated
Sylvester stones doing a movie on his
book that just came out he and I are
sitting here in our office were talking
and it gets a little heated at one point
I said listen you know what's this whole
story with Apple you know government
telling Apple you should give us all the
access to the information because if a
terrorist uses the phone we need to know
this kind of stuff you know and FBI is
going to the DMV to get all these
pictures ID to track citizens what's
this all about and that just never got
approved and he says look I'm not
telling you they're doing the right
thing or the wrong thing but here's what
I can tell you he says technology is
outpacing and out advancing our laws the
laws that we have today were written 60
years ago the laws are not adjusted to
today's times and speed we have to
understand the speed is so fast that the
laws have to be adjusted because the
Christ is no longer a nuclear war it's a
cybersecurity war and we have to be
prepared for that I'm not saying it's
right or wrong and I Saturn a so you
know that's pretty interesting thing to
say to the Iranian people watch this a
lot of Iranian principles worked
pre-social media pre-internet a lot of
it work Iran has to figure out who they
want to be look a lot of woman in Iran
look at woman in US and they're like
wait a minute
it was there really a billionaire
youngest billionaire 20 years old 21
years old she's worth a billion dollars
running a company generally is that
really happening our woman really
running multiple businesses and yet
everywhere you look at their being how
come we don't have that in Iran they're
thinking that a opportunity to become an
entrepreneur are you kidding me if
Barack Obama's the president now a
former apprentice he's a president I
want those kinds of opportunities well
in Iran so either those talents is gonna
be inspired to leave and come to America
just like my family and many Iranians
came over here or Iran's gotta kind of
just and say look what do we want to do
what direction do we want to go what
principles are working and adapt because
the same old principles in today's times
in today's speed today's technology
today's social media are gonna
constantly get pushed back and in events
you're gonna have to face with some kind
of bullies here very soon so it's like a
guy who is 5 6 128 pounds fighting the
guy that 6 5 280 pounds
black belt six degree jiu-jitsu trained
UFC it's not a fight and sometimes like
Rowhani the president recently in front
of a congregation gets up and he says
when we say death upon America were not
saying death upon the American people
were saying death upon Trump and John
Bolton and the leaders of America that's
really what we're saying and people like
oh okay what do you mean oh okay
it's still death upon the president of
United States that you're talking about
in a speech publicly recorded being
shown all over the news nationwide so
Iran has to also pick their fights and
know some of these allies have the right
relationship that you need for these
other countries to do business with you
so I hope Iran is going to kind of make
the right maneuvers long term not just
right now based on hey nobody can push
us around again I'm giving you my
thoughts I may be right I may be wrong
but if this video prompted you'd want to
go to a little bit more research
everything I talked about I'll put the
links below for you to go look through
it and hopefully gonna do your own
research by the way if you like the
content like this I got two other videos
I want you to watch one of them is
explaining brexit on how I view it and
the other one is explaining the
venezuela issued has taken place with
their oil and their sanctions would
Maduro the way i view it if you want to
watch brexit click over here if you want
to watch - well click over here if you
haven't subscribed please do so and if
you got any thoughts comment below take
everybody bye-bye